اجراءات امنيه مشدده اعلنت وزاره الداخليه
وقياده الجيش في شرق البلاد البدء في
تنفيذها لضبط الامن والحد من ارتفاع معدل
الجريمه ببنغازي ثاني اكبر المدن الليبيه
الحمله هذه التعليمات سيدي قائد العام
جميع جميع الظواهر السلبيه داخل بلديه
بنغازي من
مباني خارج الشرعيه خارج المخططات الاكشاك
الغير مرخصه
الطرق المقفله
المروجين المخدرات المروجين
الخمور الهجره غير شرعيه السلاح بدون
ترخيص تجار الاسلحه جميع الظواهر السلبيه
بتعليمات من القائد العام لازم بنغازي
تنضف
لم يكن هذا الوجود الامني ممكنا في السابق
في عدد من مناطق المدينه بسبب انتشار
تجاره المخدرات والفساد قبل وصول الحمله
الامنيه لها والقضاء على مروجها
كانت لازم تكون ضرب يد من حديد لهذا لو
كان الفساد اللي نحن بصراحه فرحانين بها
كلها يعني شنو التمنوا لمدينه بنغازي
وجميع مدن ليبيا نتمنى لهم الخير
هذا شيء ايجابي للدوله ومنظور اخر ان
الدوله يعني في الاحسن حتى صورتنا تبان
للاحسن ان الوضع للاسف اصبح كارث يعني في
مكان بعض المناطق يعني
الدوله لها حقل القوه القاهره سموا فيها
يعني
قوه القانون بحكم قوه القانون يعني
فالدوله نعم
ايدينها طبعا
عمليه السلوك بعض الاشخاص يعني محسوبين
على مثلا على الجهات الامنيه برضو تبي
واعتقد انهم ماشيين في الشيء هذا فانتمنى
التوفيق للجميع يعني
حاصروا السلاح المنتشر وجمعه وتفعيل قانون
الجرائم الالكترونيه هي ابرز ملامح الخطه
الامنيه الجديده ببغازي لازاله الاكشاك
والمباني غير المرخصه وتفعيل اقسام المرور
ومحاسبه رجال الشرطه المتهمين في قضايا
التزوير والفساد
مع تاييد وترحيب شعبي واسع باطلاق الخطه
الامنيه المشتركه بين الجيش والشرطه تبرز
تحديات تعاون المواطنين مع الحمله وقدره
الجهه الامنيه على الاستمرار فيها وان
يكون القانون كالموت لا يستثني احدا محمد
مسعود بنغازي العربيه